ist oder Saures
saures gut wusstest du dass wenn es so
bleibt wie jetzt in 7 Jahren der
Klimawandel nicht mehr aufzuhalten ist
wusstest du dass deswegen bis 2050 200
Millionen Menschen hier zu Hause
verlieren können das ist unangenehm und
wusstest du auch dass 16% aller
Deutschen laut einer Studie sagen dass
sie offen fremdenfeindlich sind cool
oder nee interessiert dich ansonsten was
dein Onkel zuum ostkonflikt sagt kannst
du bitte gehen und ich habe noch ein
paar Fotos von der letzten
Weihnachtsfeier die Du noch nicht
gesehen hast hoch das ist aber nicht
deine Frau oder okay ich hab Sch ade
warum nicht gleich so